hola de nuevo veamos si podemos darnos
un entendimiento intuitivo del por qué
la balanza de cuenta corriente y la
balanza de cuenta que tal se equilibra
como puedes ver aquí tengo a versiones
simplificadas de la cuenta corriente y
de la cuenta capital para eeuu en el año
iremos aquí viendo línea por línea
analizando qué dice esto sobre las
transferencias reales en términos de
dólares y bueno aquí primero tengo la
cuenta corriente y tenemos aquí un
déficit de balanza comercial
la balanza comercial es un registro de
las importaciones y exportaciones de un
país y aquí tenemos déficit vemos que el
país hace más importaciones que
exportaciones lo que quiere decir que
hay una salida de fondos y como tú
puedes ver este número de aquí domina la
cuenta corriente ves que la balanza
comercial es la que abarca más entonces
ahora vamos con el 95 punto 7 billones
los cuales nos dicen que en el 2007 eeuu
obtuvo esa cantidad más en activos que
poseen extranjeros que lo que los
extranjeros poseían en activos
americanos entonces tenemos aquí a los
ingresos netos
de fondos ingresos netos por inversión
pero luego como tú puedes ver aquí
eeuu de un más que eso al resto del
mundo esto pudo hacer el gobierno
ayudando a otro país o un ciudadano
americano enviando dinero a un familiar
en el extranjero o donaciones incluso
donaciones aunque vemos que la balanza
comercial es lo que realmente domina en
la cuenta corriente y es exactamente lo
que tú puedes ver aquí son menos 700
10.8 billones ahora si miramos la cuenta
corriente de una manera estricta y
precisa especialmente si nos enfocamos
en lo que es la balanza comercial vemos
lo que llega a eeuu lo que está llegando
lo pondré aquí esto llega y acá es el
resto del mundo el resto del mundo vemos
que eeuu por la mayor parte está
obteniendo un montón de cosas y pagando
por ello pero además está dando un
poquito más y eso es lo que ellos
compran ellos compran un montón de cosas
pagan por eso y entonces el resto del
mundo lo que obtiene es neto 700 10.8
millones entonces para este lado en esta
dirección van
netos 710 punto 8 billones eso es lo que
el resto del mundo está obteniendo de
eeuu entonces está en dólar
estadounidense claro así que voy a poner
aquí un dólar aunque sabemos que ese no
es el panorama completo también tenemos
el cambio en la propiedad de los activos
que es la cuenta capital entonces lo que
haré es enfocarme en estas dos en estas
dos primeras líneas de aquí estas dos de
la cuenta capital aquí tenemos los
cambios en la compra de activos
estadounidenses y tenemos la compra
estadounidense de activos extranjeros la
mayoría de las veces cuando las personas
hablan sobre la cuenta capital están
hablando sobre estas dos primeras líneas
aunque técnicamente la cuenta capital
abarca todo todo esto estos tres puntos
y estos dos puntos abarcan una
definición limitada de lo que es la
cuenta capital por lo que podemos ver
los extranjeros están comprando mucho
más en activos que eeuu comprando al
extranjero podemos ver aquí en estos
datos pero voy a sacar la calculadora
para ver qué onda que está pasando así
que los extranjeros están comprando
2000 57.7 billones lo cual es un ingreso
para eeuu entonces ellos pagan en
dólares para comprar inmuebles valores y
todo lo demás pero eeuu sale y convierte
ese dinero en moneda extranjera y compra
activos en otros países entonces este
número de aquí indica una salida de
dinero entonces menos 128 9.5 eso es
calculando solamente estas dos primeras
líneas es la cantidad sale la cantidad
de 768 puntos 2 billones una manera de
verlo en una base neta extranjeros están
comprando 768 puntos 2 billones en
activos estadounidenses así que voy a
poner aquí flechas para que esto quede
claro tenemos que extranjeros están
obteniendo activos de eeuu y el
intercambio los estadounidenses obtienen
768 puntos 2 billones en moneda entonces
tú como tú puedes ver este asunto está
bastante interesante los americanos
están gastando en activos extranjeros
pero alguna parte de ese dinero es en
donaciones o para familiares extranjeros
aquí son 700 10.8 billones pero una
cantidad más elevada que eso regresa por
extranjeros comprando activos
estadounidenses y aquí viene una
pregunta bastante interesante cómo es
posible esto cómo es posible que llegue
más de lo que sale la única manera de
hacer esto posible es que los
extranjeros hagan más compras que lo que
eeuu está enviando al mundo esto es que
primeramente en primer lugar es primero
que todo que los extranjeros tengan
dinero entonces digamos que ellos tienen
en el banco central esta reserva de
dólar entonces tienen un montoncito de
reserva de dólar tu puedes imaginar al
resto del mundo teniendo estas reservas
y la única manera que esto sea posible
para que ellos estén enviando más
dólares que lo que eeuu les está
enviando al resto del mundo es que ellos
gasten sus reservas de dólares que
tienen y para hallar lo que ellos están
gastando más que eeuu vamos a calcular
la diferencia que hay entre estos dos
valores de aquí
eeuu está enviando bueno primero vamos a
poner aquí aquí esta cantidad que ellos
están enviando a ellos a eeuu entonces
estamos
estén viendo a ellos mayormente por la
balanza comercial pero en general por el
déficit de cuenta corriente que llevan
710 punto 8 millones eso da eso da 57.4
billones que no están en la contabilidad
de lo que eeuu está enviando al mundo
así que esencialmente ellos van a
obtener de sus reservas estadounidenses
57.4 billones para lo que se logró la
diferencia calculada igual de hecho es
exactamente eso lo que tenemos aquí 57.4
millones entonces las reservas foráneas
tendrán que gastar 57.4 billones y lo
podremos ver como un cambio oficial neto
en reservas extranjeras cambio oficial
neto en reservas extranjeras y en
general vemos esto como los bancos
centrales de otros gobiernos usando las
reservas de divisas extranjeras y usando
ese dinero en mercados de divisas
mayormente para que las personas de su
país para que la gente de su país pueda
comprar activos americanos comprar cosas
donar o transferir dinero en alguna
manera a eeuu y bueno aquí aquí ya vimos
esencialmente las razones por las que
estas dos la cuenta corriente y la
cuenta capital se equilibran cualquier
cantidad en la que éstas nos fallen
cualquier cantidad en la que no
concuerden donde la balanza de cuenta
corriente y la definición limitada de
cuenta capital no concuerden tendrá que
hacer la cantidad de los cambios en
reservas extranjeras en este caso una
cantidad neta de más dólares están
siendo enviados a eeuu así que en algún
lugar del mundo alguien o algún algún
país agotó sus reservas en dólares para
que aquí haya 57.4 billones ahora por lo
tanto ya vimos que el cálculo en efecto
nos da que la cuenta corriente y la
cuenta capital si se equilibra